I guess uh because this is a workshop
about theory and practice I should start
with um the way that theoreticians like
to view constraint satisfaction problems
so they will tell you that you have some
variables every variable has a finite
domain
they will tell you that you have some
constraints Each of which has a scope so
the scope of a constraint is the
variables over which it's defined
and then there's a set of feasible
tuples uh over this scope and then
they'll start selling you that opens
Transformer Network
and the idea here is to give every
variable a value from its domain such
that each constraint is satisfied
just like in sat there is a bit of a
divide between the way that
theoreticians and practitioners think
about constraint programming
practitioners will tell you the
following okay we have finite variables
we have these integer variables we have
array variables set variables graph
variables partition variables
and then the constraint is something
like x i plus y J equals z so here x is
an array potentially of integer
variables I is a variable Y is an array
of integer variables uh J again an
integer variable and Z also a variable
so potentially variables all over the
place
we might save it for example all
different so variables a b c and d will
have to take different values
and we might say something like knapsack
so knapsack which is which is already NP
complete we might Express this as a
constraint so we might have some weights
and some profits so these are
potentially arrays of variables
how many items we can pick could be sum
up to give us again variables of total
weight and total profit
and then we have something that we want
to solve like lexicographical
optimization or we might want a diverse
set of solutions or we might want to
find a parity front
in a particular we are quite often
talking about optimization problems
where
[Music]
um
we really don't want to untapped as an
answer so we are optimizing something or
we really want a solution rather than
that we're trying to prove that
something doesn't exist
and modern constraint programming people
will also tell you about search so they
will say oh it's a good idea to branch
on these variables
so I thought I'd put up a bit of a
dictionary for people who are not used
to constraint programming talks
so when I say a problem what you should
what you should think of is a high level
description of what you're trying to do
with parameters
when I say model
I mean a description of how we encode a
problem
when I say instance I mean we are going
to take a model and apply it to a set of
parameters and we're going to get
something out where we can solve so you
can think of this as being like your CNF
when I say a solution
I mean a model
when I say propagation I I mean
propagation but it's more complicated
when I say variable heuristic I mean
something a bit like visits when I say
value heuristic I mean polarity
and when I say no good I mean a learned
Clause but it's backwards so it's the
negation of a learned Clause so it's
it's something that is no good okay
uh and then once we've done this Saturn
CP are basically the same thing except
for the terminology
maybe a bit more
we talk a lot about modeling in CP we
have many modeling languages there's
Essence mini zinc xcsp uh probably many
of us
there is a fairly large gap between what
we use as specifies and what the solver
gets in many situations
so the going from a high level model to
the low level model that solvers
actually solve is is quite often a big
deal
people also use specific solvers
directly as libraries so it's quite
common to embed a constraint solver
inside a larger application
yeah
here's an example this is a mini zinc
problem so I'll not go over this in
detail but everything up to here is just
part of the input so we're saying we're
going to be given some flower or we're
going to be given some banana which is
an integer we're going to be given sugar
we're going to make some cakes uh these
we're saying here VAR so these are
things we're actually finding
and Visa constraints this is this is
actually an integer linear program
um we have our objective and the most
important feature of any modeling
language is a way of outputting the
solution so that the user can read it
um
this feature is vital and it does kind
of affect how you can compile the
problem
alternatively since we have some people
from Saint Andrews in the room this is
an example of modeling in the essence
modeling language again I'm not going to
details but we're starting to say here
find me a sequence which can be any size
up to Horizon of total functions from
this set to this set
um so we're really encoding structured
variables in a high level modeling
language here
such fat and a bunch of constraints this
is this is in fact a planning type
problem
xcsp I I don't think any of the csb
people in the room so I can say that I
really don't like this but there is an
XML modeling language that somehow
embeds things that are not XML so you
still have to write a parser in this I I
don't know but it's popular in France
you can use a solver directly this is
how you would use the G-Code solver so
somehow you are defining a class that
has these variables that represent your
problem you're defining these
constraints and you can really program
anything you want to about the solver so
branching heuristics propagation Etc
uh apparently people like python now uh
we have a python modeling language that
is suddenly extremely popular
so this is sudoku this is probably the
nicest way of writing out Sudoku that
I've seen
in particular in constraint programming
we care a lot about finding a good model
for a problem or even finding multiple
good models and then solving them all
simultaneously with what we call
channeling constraints between them
um in contrast to sat where you are
given the CNF and you must obey the CNF
you must not question the CNF in CP we
will change the model as much as we like
um we consider it completely fair game
to solve the problem in a different way
to the way that we're being given uh
some of this is automated some of this
relies upon human modelers
the question always comes up is is when
is CP actually good uh in particularly
in comparison to sat
my rough answer to this is okay what if
we are mixing several different kinds of
constraints so for example difference
constraints logical constraints integer
linear inequalities
if we're mixing these constraints and
they interact in in interesting ways
then somehow the CP solving techniques
based upon consistency seem to be quite
good at tackling this
but other area is
um sometimes satin Coatings are just too
big I work a lot on subgraph solvers the
encoding size for subgraph isomorphism
in SATs uh will kill you much faster
than it will in CP so there's an
advantage to not having to write out all
the constraints in CNF
when you want a human understandable
model I think this is I think this is
potentially a big deal going forwards
um
if we're a bit careful we can rank
minisinker Essence so that a human can
understand what we're solving I would
argue that very few people can read the
dimax CNF format and understand really
what that what's going on there
are other areas where you have
optimization problems but you have hard
constraints
um so you have some constraints that you
absolutely cannot violate
um again in this case I would argue the
constraint programming is potentially
much better than trying for example
classical local search
foreign
what we heard this morning I mean so why
can't I express these CP problems uh
directly for an smt solver I mean it's a
different kinds of constraints and right
yes so
I I will get on to this but I think
CP solvers and smt solvers are
converging
so um traditionally CP didn't do close
learning and smt had very weak Theory
solvers
uh now modern CP servers do close
learning and smt is getting stronger and
stronger
so yeah they're they're getting very
close to each other now I think
so if we want to do this translation we
should think of like a constraint is
like somehow a theory or a like what's
the translation back and forth yes uh
I'm going to go on and Define
constraints in a slightly interesting
way so this will probably answer your
question
foreign
s work we have
behind the scenes something some way of
storing variables
um quite often we can have multiple
representations so for small variables
we might use bit sets large domains we
might be still bounce
some servers optimized if you give lots
of Boolean variables
um
circuit variables might have their own
representation some solvers do have set
variables internally other solvers
compile everything down to integer
variables
there's as far as I can tell no
agreements on whether solvers for CP
should be copying or trailing oh my own
solver does both and there does not seem
to be any difference between the two um
uh so copying versus trailing when we
branch
we can either copy the entire state of
the solver
and then when we backtrack we just
forget it or trailing we use these
reversible data structures like insat
oh
this this was a big debate in the
community for about 10 years
um as far as I can tell it's completely
irrelevant on Modern Hardware
so constraints here is here is a
somewhat interesting definition of a
constraint the constraint is really
something that defines an inference
algorithm or a propagator
okay
what are these inference algorithms do
so at minimum they have to tell you
whether or not they are satisfied so if
I have an all different constraint it
has to tell me are these things actually
all different or not if I have an
integer linear inequality I it has to
tell me
our SV inequality actually respected or
not
ideally these constraints also give us
information about inferring something so
if I have
um
uh X Plus 100y is greater than or equal
to 80 and x is 0 1 then it's going to
tell me that y has to be at least one
here okay
um in newer solvers uh hopefully
constraints can actually give you
precise explanations for uh why things
aren't feasible
uh we will have a talk later today on
using even more information where they
can tell you which values in a
constraint are most likely to occur
and the other thing here and I I don't
know whether I don't know if smt has
adopted this yet but in CP our
constraints are usually stateful
algorithms so we're going to be doing
quite expensive computations
and we don't want to do these
computations from scratch every time the
constraint is is called
um so there's there's a lot of work into
putting State into these algorithms that
somehow remains valid on backtrack
we do occasionally represent constraints
as a list of feasible tuples possibly in
clever ways this does happen but we try
to avoid it
we already heard about consistency this
morning I'm just going to talk a little
bit about it
um
our basic notion is Arc consistency
specifically where we have constraints
between two variables
I'm going to say that a constraint is
Arc consistent if for each value in the
first variable there exists a value in
the second variable that supports this
assignment and vice versa
and then for General constraints I'm
going to Define generalized out
consistency just to mean that
um every value in every variable exists
in at least one solution to this
constraint
but we can also Define other Notions
like bounds consistency just looking at
the highest and lowest values in the
domain
finding consistency can be hard
um we consider integer linear equalities
even over zero one variables this is
effectively a subset sum problem so just
determining whether there is a solution
to misconstraint is is already NP hard
solvers potentially will still do this
anyway if you give it a constraint with
small numbers involved
we can take this constraint we can turn
it into two integer linear inequalities
uh generalize that consistency on two
inequalities separately is easy we can
we can just look at the bounds of the
variables
um
this does not give you the same so
consistency on a decomposition does not
give you the same as consistency on
where you started off with in particular
if we're dealing with integer variables
then we see this has no Solutions
so consistency should tell you this
but consistency on these inequalities
doesn't really tell you anything so the
representation matters it really matters
exactly how you specify a constraint
and the question is do we actually care
about consistency
um
so I believe for historical reasons
some people think that generalized art
consistency is absolutely the right
thing to do for every constraint
propagator
oh
there are a couple of reasons for this
um one is that all different was the
first Global constraint that was really
just discovered in detail
and there is a very nice generalized art
consistency propagator for all different
and then after this people started
saying okay so we should look for
generalized uh consistency propagators
for every constraint
the other reason
is if the only thing we can do is look
at one constraint at a time and start
deleting values and variables generalize
that consistency is the strongest
possible thing you can do
which again this this is potentially a
nice property although these days silver
roofers tend to care about what we do
fast rather than what can we do if it
gives us a nice theoretical properties
so I will solve knapsack at every
request at every recursive call in a
solver potentially if I think this is
the best thing to do to help me solve
the rest of the problem
okay
propagation uh
unlike in CNF constraints can propagate
more than once so
um constraint a can propagate and tell
me something constraint B then
propagates and this gives me some new
information which lets constraint a
propagate again so
essentially what we can do is run every
single constraint over and over again
until we reach a fixed point
uh the obvious question here is is this
fixed Point unique
the answer is it depends if every
constraint is generalized about
consistency yes if every constraint has
a certain monotonicity property yes some
constraints some constraint propagators
in practice do not have these properties
oh
there is a huge amount of engineering
effort in how do we propagate all these
constraints as quickly as possible
we can do generalizations of two watch
literals except potentially you have to
watch an awful lot of things
uh we have events we have multiple
constraint cues
um
sometimes you can determine a static
ordering of a constraints that will work
um
but this this in general is a very
difficult problem is to figure out how
to run your constraints as quickly as
possible
the thing here is constraint propagation
is slow uh compared to sub solvers
we might be running very expensive
propagators many times a full round of
constraint propagation could potentially
take seconds to complete
but also constraint propagation is very
fast oh for some problems with the right
representation we can infer thousands or
millions of facts per clock cycle
um so even if you somehow had a satin
coding that gave you the same level of
consistency as a CP solver
for some of these constraints the CP
solver gets there so much faster
potentially we have these better
constant factors from propagators and
the other thing is not having to deal
with a large encoding is sometimes a
really big deal in practice so this goes
both ways constraint propagation is both
very slow and very fast
okay we also do search and constraint
programming we do backtracking search we
propagate it every every node in the
search tree
we quite often specify variable and
value ordering heuristics so uh a bit
like vsids and polarity uh quite often
the modeler will specify these
we we know some good rules on
um how to specify search
we will also quite often restrict the
solver to only branching on certain
variables which we call the decision
variables
um
again this is
this is some something with a good model
I can do that they'll have an intuition
that you should only branch on these
variables and everything else should
just be calculated
it's a surprising to me that the modeler
gives you like which variables to branch
on typically what happens from my
experience is the modeler we say okay
well here's a cryptographic problem you
should pay into the keys which is almost
surely the worst thing you can do
because yes right so and that's the
direct and immediate intuition of every
modeler who works in cryptography and
then you have to teach them so I'm like
usually I don't trust any of this I just
like ignore like the best thing you can
do is ignore actually reverse is usually
the best thing you can do
what is your experience with this
a good modeler knows this
um
the thing is a lot of CP very a lot of
CP encodings will look like okay I am
producing a timetable I'm going to have
my timetabling variables that tells me
okay what am I going to schedule at
which time in the timetable and then I'm
going to have these hundreds of
auxiliary variables that are used for
calculating you know Staffing costs Etc
um
if we think of a simple Workforce
scheduling problem it is actually a good
idea to decide okay I want this person
to work on this day
and it's a really bad idea to decide
that
um seven people are going to work on
this day
but somehow you you have this you have
this variable because you want to start
talking about the capacity of
um you know capacity constraints on how
many people work so
there are certainly variables where if
you branch on these variables it will
completely kill you
there are variables where branching on
on them is moderately sensible
um
but what tends to happen is
you need to find a good branching
variable somehow you let the modeler
give you a hint and then the solver will
start doing something a bit Visa D it'll
say okay which variables tend to appear
in conflicts and it will know to branch
on those
but uh
there are defaults in most solvers
um they're okay
this is a point in V6 we we start saying
okay over which variables appear in lots
of conflicts or which constraints appear
in lots of conflicts and we can start
um biases we could say this constraint
is Fair times heavier than the distance
if a modeler is good we have program
program search you can do things like uh
branching on Expressions so
um there's a car assembly line example
you don't decide I am going to produce
this car on this day you decide I am
going to produce a red car on this day
and somehow this is
this is a really big deal and I think
Siri people can potentially tell us
something about this this is a bit like
branching on extension variables
oh
possibly uh you you might disagree with
this one
I mean extended resolution right yes
that represents constraint and you're
this constraint is your is a horrible
boundary extended resolution no
it's it's yes
um this this is effectively branching on
an extension variable of this reifying
of constraints
um although you could argue that you
could have just put these variables in
the original model and solve this
building that way so yeah
reach outs we do do restarts they seem
to move much less frequent than in SATs
for whatever reason
um they seem to be mostly about boosting
weighted variable ordering heuristics of
practice so telling us how to Branch
um
we can do notebooks from restart
sufficiently so effectively um
we do some complete branching over a
subtree we have an efficient way of
saying never visit that Century again
but finally this is this is getting into
the connection with smt so in a in a
traditional propagate we'd say okay
we've made we've guessed some
assignments G and now we know that X is
not equal to 5.
one way of thinking about this is we're
going to generate a clause that says uh
if you do all of G then X cannot be
equal to 5. we can think of this as
being a new constraint and we can add
this into the solver
um
but of course you can be much more
specific you don't have to say that all
of these guesses led to this conflict
you can say this these three very
specific things mean that X cannot be
equal to 5.
so we call this lazy close generation
one way of thinking about this is you
can have a really really strong CNF
encoding but you can create it
dynamically when you need it
okay
I thought I'd go over a bit about uh how
real different constraint is actually
implemented in solvers John told us a
little bit about this in this morning so
I will go quite quickly through this
um
here is a simple constraint satisfaction
problem so I have three zero one
variables
um
and I want them to be all different so
this is the same as uh two coloring a
triangle or
um was it you're trying to put three
holes in two pigeons and then one of the
pigeons has to have at least two holes
in it
um so unsatisfiable
one thing we could do we could decompose
this into not equals two constraints
and then think about what propagation
would do so we have a constraint X1 is
not equal to X2
we think about art consistency so if X1
takes a value 0 the next two takes a
value one that's fine if X1 takes value
one the next two takes a value zero so
that's okay if X2 is 0 x 1 is 1 and so
on so uh consistency
on the decomposition tells us nothing at
all
obviously a human will look at this and
say no no this constraint is
unsatisfiable
um so if we don't compose the constraint
what we're looking uh what we're looking
for is a propagator that will do the
same thing if propagated will tell us
straight away there is no solution to
this problem
so as we saw earlier we're going to
create this
um bipartite graph so variables on the
left values on the right an edge if a
variable could take a particular value
we can find a maximum cardinality
matching in this in polynomial time so
here
and we see that X3 is uncovered so in
this case the the best possible way of
giving variables values only gives two
of the three variables a value
either is in fact a correspondence
between uh perfect matching so matchings
that cover everything on the left hand
side and solutions to be constrained so
for example if we had an additional
value here we would now be okay
and does does anybody actually do Sudoku
solving
uh okay Karen there's two people I I
give this lecture to our undergraduates
and then ask them why they don't just
get the computer to do it for them uh
this is this is kind of a massive denial
of service attack upon human intellect I
think
okay Harem tell me if these are the
values left in the boxes what are you
going to infer when you solve this I
have no idea okay
can anyone tell me anything you can
infer
so the one on the left
box one has to has to have a value one
all right okay anything else
the two and three
how's that two three five eight two and
three yep so okay well you can try the
two and three everywhere yeah okay
anything else
foreign
so nine has to be the end I think we're
going to see something else first
five has got to be one of those next
three yeah so we we have a four five six
or four four five or four five six four
five six so we know they have to go
somewhere so
but both can't go there
uh seven nine seven eight nine eight
nine uh and I think this is this is
everything we can do okay so we need an
algorithm that will tell us this
let's let's go back and think about
consistency so I'm going to call a whole
set a set of n variables whose domains
have exactly n values between them
and there is a serum but if we so if we
find a whole set so if I can show you n
variables that have n values then none
of the other variables can take those
values
there is a theorem that um
if we can delete every single whole set
this is equivalent to deleting every
Edge from a Max from a matching graph
which cannot appear in every in any
matching
so if we can delete every whole set we
delete every value that cannot appear in
at least one way of satisfying your
constraints
um so we achieve generalized art
consistency I'm not going to prove this
to you one direction is easy One
Direction is not easy
so can we find whole sets well there are
two to be an pot potential whole set so
we can't just check them all but we also
can't enumerate every perfect matching
this is this is sharp be hard but there
is still an algorithm
roughly speaking and I'm just showing
you this to show you what solvers do
inside search
um
we're going to create the
um the value graph so variables in the
left values on the right we're going to
put in edges if a variable can take a
value we are going to find some
arbitrary matching
any Edge that's present in the matching
I'm going to turn into a directed Edge
from right to left and any of it isn't
is going to be in a left to right
I'm going to split this up into strongly
connected components using the most
beautiful algorithm in the world
and I am only going to look at edges
that go between components
and something mysterious and magical
happens here that if you if you
understand what alternating paths are
and you think about this really hard for
half an hour you'll you'll understand
why this works uh
every Edge that's left every Edge
remaining that goes from left to right
uh corresponds precisely to deletions
and every Edge remaining going from
right to left corresponds to forced
assignments
you know I'm not going to prove this I
just want you to know that during search
a constraint propagation algorithm is
uh finding lots and lots of Maximum
cardinality matchings and finding
strongly connected components all the
time
so just generalize that consistency
matter is it worth doing this
here is a Sudoku problem from the
Glasgow Herald newspaper they say it's
easy
I've solved this using the choco silver
it took me
one recursive call and 13 milliseconds
to solve this problem
this is using a decomposition
using the old different constraint it
took me 17 milliseconds and it took me
one recursive call so all different is
slower uh not worth doing
okay let's try a slightly harder
seductive puzzle we know it's harder
because the newspaper tells us it's
harder
okay using the decomposition
34 recursive calls
um 24 milliseconds to solve it
using it all different okay two
recursive calls so we've cut down the
amount of search
and I've gone from 24 milliseconds to 22
milliseconds so a clear strong advantage
to all different populations
okay this is a superior Sudoku
um
yeah
using the decomposition uh it takes us
14 nodes and 20 milliseconds using all
different so two recursive calls and 22
milliseconds now we're slower again
okay this is the world's hardest Sudoku
let's let's get a benchmark instance
that actually shows the difference
using the decomposition
um 855 recursive calls to solve
it's kind of interesting that the human
levels of difficulties do roughly
correspond to solver recursive calls
sort of a bit
using all different okay 83 recursive
calls that's surprisingly high and we go
from 57 milliseconds down to 49
milliseconds
uh so at this point the conclusion is
that 9x9 Sudoku is is too easy for
constraint solvers so
um
let's go bigger
this is the 36 by 36 Sudoku
using the decomposition uh timed out
after an hour using all different we can
solve the whole thing in 200
milliseconds and 28 recursions
um so I mean the conclusion here is
somehow the stronger propagators might
win eventually on large enhancement
Benchmark instances
um
they're not necessarily a universal win
there is a very long paper on how to
implement all different quickly
um in particular uh if you start doing
things like incremental matchings rather
than recomputing from scratch you end up
with a propagated that runs 168 times
faster
uh we need this level of research for
every single Global constraint
I will skip this because I don't think
people are awake enough but if you want
to challenge them we can go back to this
slide and you can tell me something that
a constraints program week solver can't
do
but the main point is propagationally
considers one constraints at a time uh
whereas humans can reason about multiple
constraints simultaneously
we do have various ways of combining
constraints but somehow combining
multiple constraints simultaneously is
potentially also a hard problem
but one last thing is
um this is interesting that uh Nina who
is in the room proved a long time ago
there is no polynomial sized CNF
encoding such that unit propagation on
the encoding of all different gives you
generalized out consistency so somehow a
sat solver cannot do this no matter how
good the encoding is
I think this is this is potentially
interesting
okay what else is exciting in constraint
programming um
my personal project is proof vlogging I
think we need proof logging for
constraint programming
yes and yes curious when if you were
comparing with sat solvers and the 3D
and calling because for quasiou groups
this is a long time ago I know that
satsi on this 3D encoding was better
than CP approaches using the old Leaf
constraints so which is the status right
now uh right now we know a lot more
about implementing all different than
getting it to run quickly than we did
when those experiments were carried out
um this factor of 168 I mean this this
matters
um I I know some people say oh well
different doesn't matter based upon
a slow or different propagator on fairly
small problem instances
um
if you have a fast or different
propagator and large problem instances
sometimes it matters
not not always but I don't think there's
an easy answer
print logging for CP yes we need this
constraint programming solvers do have
bugs
um
this is hard we can't just compile to
sat because the encodings might be wrong
and we might not have uh strong enough
reasoning in the SAT solver
we have all these propagators that do
all these kinds of clever reasoning
and somehow we still need a free format
that's simple to verify so what we
cannot do is have a proof format that
has 400 different rules in it for each
of the 400 Global constraints uh we will
have a talk tomorrow amazing recent
progress uh suitability and proof
fogging is exactly what we need so
cutting planes is exactly the right
proof system to justify every single
propagation algorithm
constraint based local search I put this
in because it does not satisfy karam's
definition of vocal search
we can do this
I said at the start of the talk but
we're really looking for solutions to
problems uh if your silver spits out on
sat then the business people who want
you to schedule their Factory will get
very upset and say yes but why is it
unsat and it turns out that solver says
no is is not an answer
somehow if you if you have high level
constraints you can somehow get a very
small core that can give you human
understandable explanations uh some of
the time
foreign
propagation we have a talk on this this
afternoon it's really cool so I will
skip it decision diagram solvers we
heard about these this morning these are
also really interesting but I will skip
this
parallel search we can sort of do this
in constraint programming probably
slightly more successfully than in sat
um
we have various Ways randomized work
stealing is terrible
confidence-based work stealing so
stealing based upon where you think
Solutions are likely to be
sometimes quite a lot better
embarrassingly parallel search is a bit
like Cube and Conquer it's very easy to
implement it works very well for some
problems and it's terrible for others oh
my own pet project is to abuse restarts
and value ordering heuristics and just
share No Goods this again works very
well in some circumstances and not at
all in others
we also have two competitions in the CP
Community we have a mini zinc
competition and an xcsp competition
so they don't cover a lot of solver
features they're not really the primary
driving force behind evaluating solvers
like they're in the sac Community
a lot of solvers don't compete or aren't
eligible for the competition
I think this is this is both a good
thing and a bad thing
um
okay I was going to finish with a very
brief description of how constraint
programming also gives us a way of
implementing algorithms for other
problems and I was going to tell you
about subgraph solving which is my
favorite activity and in particular how
I took everything the constraint
programming had taught us and used it to
design a subgraph solver that
uh is the state of the art until uh the
educate papers come out and then I'm
going to be second best
until I win again
um
so this kind of problem but uh Karam
inspired me that for instead of talking
about engineering I'm going to talk
about science
uh so maximum Clique I give you a graph
find me the biggest set of vertices that
are all adjacent to each other
the way still was working practices they
are very stupid they propagate very
quickly using bit parallelism they use
graph coloring as a bound they color the
vertices so adjacent vertices have to
get different colors so you can use this
as a bound and they iterate from right
to left so whichever vertex was the last
one but got the highest color you branch
on this vertex first
um this is absolutely the established
wisdom in the creek solving community
and the reason is vertices in the
rightmost color class are generally
expected to have a high probability of
belonging to a maximum Clique and then
if you find a really good clip quickly
this helps you you reduce the amount of
branching you have to do it gives you a
strong Bound in the algorithm
uh
nice easy scientifically testable claim
here
um it's completely untrue I I actually
tested it
uh particular route to left ordering is
still best even the V algorithm is only
proving optimality and better click
algorithms have worse anytime Behavior
so as you as click algorithms have
improved
it takes more longer and longer to spit
out a good solution
I'm not going to go into much detail on
this but CP gives us a way of
understanding branching heuristics I am
going to hypothesize that when you
produce a coloring the rightmost color
class is going to be smaller than uh any
of the other color classes this is a bit
like smallest domain first so what
greedy coloring and branching is
actually doing is emulating smallest
domain first which we sort of understand
and I can test this so this is what
would happen if color classes were not
commuted um so if if color classes were
equally likely to be of equal size all
over the place
this is what would happen if color
classes are completely sorted so we
always have the smallest colored glasses
last and this is what we see in practice
and we see more stuff is up here so it
means color classes are approximately
sorted by size
we can look at what happens if we go so
a number of recursive calls on random
graphs if we use the default ordering if
we sorted sort it and if we sort things
so we can reduce the search base size by
20 25 again confirming the hypothesis
has almost no impact on runtime because
sorting is expensive and it was very
hard to publish this paper because the
algorithms venues I sent it to said
um who cares you've not produced a
faster algorithm oh
CP took this paper so this is uh this is
why I started being a constraint
programmer
to do science I am going to argue that
science on Sat solvers on Industrial
instances is like saying to the
Alchemists please go and explain
biochemistry
that same for some really simple
experiment so let's take a simple click
solver let's take simple problem
instances to random graphs
uh the one thing I'm going to do is very
accurate measurements in a huge sample
size so this is a million core hours of
time
uh about a billion problem instances we
can see some interesting things happen
as a very edge probability on how hard
it is to solve problems on random graphs
this looks like a nice easy curve until
you zoom in and you see a very strange
Wiggly bits
if you understand phase transitions you
might think that this has something to
do with it and you would be right
we can look at how long it's defined
versus prove Optimal Solutions in these
random graphs we can start breaking
things down by actual Witnesses so um
if if the actual maximum click size is
small then it's harder to solve and if
the actual maximum quick size is Big
then it's easier to solve an average
we can start saying oh maybe this is
because there are more witnesses uh not
that simple
and we can look at any time Behavior
using a good heuristic where we're
seeing that we start off finding small
clicks and then we finish quickly
versus uh using a bad heuristic which
actually finds good Solutions faster
um I just wanted to put this up there as
a sort of thing that you can do if
you're dealing with much simpler solvers
I will stop there thank you
and for some questions
can you hear me
I can hear your voice it says
um you said that uh restarts are less
frequently necessary than in set solvers
do you have a personal explanation for
this
oh I I can hypothesize that we're not
really learning very much uh
if if you look at what restarts actually
help you with in a classical CP solver
they they help you with your branching
heuristics
but somehow if we're not doing Clause
learning it doesn't help us learn better
things
so my hypothesis is
if you're not doing learning then you're
not getting very much out of the
restarts they are relatively expensive
to do but they do help you decide how to
Branch later on
um
this this is what I think is going on
although
uh
I could not tell you how to design an
experiment that would test specifically
this claim
okay thank you
yeah so do you have something similar to
face saving when it comes to polarity
selection uh
yes so we call this uh value ordering
heuristics
um quite often the
quite often there is really a correct
thing to do so either you either you
want to give variables uh low values or
you want to give variables higher values
and quite often the model will specify
this
we don't have good automated ways of
figuring this out that I can there is a
good default heuristic in solvers for
variable ordering somehow value ordering
is
is trickier
um
yes that's uh open problem I believe
yeah
the quick examples you show were based
on random yes random grade I mean did
you try things like planted clicks or
which you could like also
I mean when people actually want to find
the maximum click they might be doing
sequence alignment or something like
that
are there other uh good sources of of
data because because I I know from the
experience which said that that random
problems are completely different from
oh yeah yeah yes I mean the aim of the
experiment is not to explain every
single aspect of why clicks always work
in practice the the only thing I'm
trying to do is formulate the question
which is simple enough that I can answer
it convincingly
um so yes in in practice uh click
solvers use on all kinds of graphs
um and we have no idea why they work
I it's time to follow up on The Middle's
question about the faith about the face
saving or value selection so in 2018 we
did some study on this and we concluded
this idea about like simulating local
search seems very effective and that's
the idea where you say the phase is
similar to what Medela was talking about
and we saw it somehow looks like some
automated large neighborhood search in
our experiments on the music benchmarks
it made a huge difference for many many
Ventures
so I would say that's a very good way of
automatically doing the physiology
selection years it doesn't work for all
problems but for a lot of them it does
really really well
yeah although it doesn't seem to have
made it into the solvents as a default
yet which is so we have it yeah I
haven't put the geese implements or our
tools also implemented so it's in the
solvers okay that's good to know
um you said that the pseudobullion proof
logging seems like the right model for
you but the problems you're encoding
don't necessarily have Boolean value
zero one value variables but you think
you can encode enough of you can use uh
zero one encodings of enough things to
be interesting for you so we'll be a
talk on this tomorrow so uh okay I'll
I'll leave that once event if that
sounds good
what one more question
not really questioned this time maybe
just a cheeky observation about the
value ordering thing
here inside it's an open problem but of
course having a good value ordering
like at the extreme is finding the
solution yes so I think there are limits
on how well you can do in value
orderings
thank our speaker again
[Applause]
yesterday in my uh hurry to make